hey guys how's it going it's Justine
back with more iPhone videos I know I
know
I definitely posted a lot during launch
week and a lot of you guys who have
subscribed for vlogs or cooking videos
we're like what's happening but for most
of you guys who know me I'm sure you
weren't surprised I plan on doing the
week with iPhone but I felt like I had
posted so many videos within a week that
I thought maybe I would just wait and do
it two weeks with iPhone so here we are
it's been about two weeks since I got
the iPhone 10 it really is a beautiful
device so the first week that I had it
was basically filming and shooting and
editing videos about the phone so I
didn't really feel like I got a chance
to try it out and use it in sort of an
everyday normal setting like I normally
would so don't ring our testing week we
tried out a bunch of things the first
thing that we tried out that I didn't
even share on my channel because my
sister post of the video is we did an
underwater test would face ID work
underwater and number two would your
phone actually work underwater the
answer is no it doesn't the screen
doesn't work on water since this was our
video she volunteered to use her phone
to do this test currently her phone is
still working perfectly fine the ACMA 10
is rated to be able to withstand at
least thirty minutes underwater it's
recommended that you don't go past three
point three feet which thankfully the
pool that we were in was about three
feet cuz my sister dropped her phone and
we both like
it for him to be quite difficult to go
underwater try to keep your eyes open
while swiping up and trying to see if
the phone is actually responding to your
face in this test we did conclude that
the phone does not work underwater you
weren't able to swipe up it also didn't
recognize her face
we did have some difficulties with face
ID trying to recognize each of us with
sunglasses on in very bright conditions
so the reason for this is because if
it's super reflective the phone is
unable to see your eyes in this bright
light and if you have the attention
awareness on if it can't see your eyes
it's not gonna unlock your phone the way
that you can get around this is turning
off the attention to Huertas so
basically you won't have to look at your
phone this does make face ID a little
bit less secure so that means if
somebody comes up to you they can swipe
up and unlock your phone with attention
awareness on if somebody tried to do
that to you you would have to be looking
at it for it to unlock it has been a
little bit frustrating when I'm outside
walking my dog with my sunglasses on and
it's super bright and I'm trying to use
face ID and it's not unlocking him and
he's pulling me super hard going to the
bathroom and then I'm trying to clean
the bathroom up but I'm trying to use my
phone and unlock it and it's not working
so normally effectively I'm going to be
in a situation where I'm gonna have
sunglasses on it's super bright I do
turn off the attention awareness but for
the most part I have been keeping it on
because it is an extra layer of security
other than that I've been pretty
impressed with face ID I know a lot of
people have been saying with they're
having problems some of my friends
they're saying it's not recognizing me
it's taking too long even at first my
sister was having an issue where it was
taking a while to recognize her and I
think the reason for this is a lot of
people when they first set up their
phones it says hey its face ID times set
it up and you're kind of in a hurry you
want to set up your phone you're not
really paying attention you're just sort
of moving your head around and I feel
like that first set up it doesn't get a
really good read on your face so if you
are having this problem I definitely
recommend going back in rescanning your
face and seeing if that helps another
thing that I tried was what if I looked
like a zombie what if my face was
completely unrecognizable will face ID
recognize me I decided to go all out I
had this incredible special effects
makeup artist Dan Gilbert come to my
house make me look like a zombie and see
if we could fool the face ID now one of
the things that I read in the comments
is a lot of you guys are suspect because
you sent Justine during this whole
process you were unlocking your face
from beginning to end and the thing with
face ID is it learns your face so
perhaps this entire time that I was
getting my makeup done I was unlocking
my phone maybe the phone was learning my
face throughout the whole process which
is of
very very very very valid point and to
that I don't really know I don't know if
that's the case now the reason that I
decided to obscure most of the bottom of
my face is because that previous day
that I'd met Dan we did something for
another shoot where I was a zombie and I
obscured most of my eyes and most of my
forehead so I thought I've been unlocked
with most of the top of my face I'm
scared it's gotta be something down here
one of the things that I did notice is
that when you turn off the attention
awareness is it's not actively seeking
for your eyes so it doesn't lock your
phone a little bit faster so again if
you are having some issues with it
unlocking slow or it's out recognizing
your face try turning that off try
rescanning and let me know if that works
for you going back to the sunglasses I
tested out probably like 15 to 20 pairs
of sunglasses to see if they would
unlock but I was right here in a
controlled environment where there's no
sunlight it's my studio lights so with
that I'm not having a lot of reflection
so all those sunglasses worked indoors
but did they work outdoors and not so
much I also heard that people were
saying if they are able to unlock their
phone using their reflection in the
mirror hmm let's try it it unlocked yes
it works so it looks like face ID does
work with a reflection of yourself in
the mirror interesting but it doesn't
work with a printed picture of yourself
one of the things that I was worried
about with his phone is because it's so
much smaller and I was so used to having
the plus size phones that I wasn't going
to like this as much as I do
surprisingly having a smaller phone is
incredible I can fit it so much easier
into my purses into my pants pockets
into my yoga pants I've got like a
little side pocket thing when I'm
running or hiking or not really running
closely if just walking the dog around
the block it's so great to not have such
a massive phone like I previously did so
the form factor of the 10 is comparable
to an iPhone 8 or any of those phones
that are that size but the screen size
is actually larger than the iPhone 8
plus which kind of puts this in the most
perfect sweet spot for the size of a
phone I know what you're saying what
about the knotch
do you love it do you hate it honestly I
am not really sure I feel like I'm kind
of 50/50 because there are some times
where I'm like man just don't trying to
watch something and then as little notch
is there and it's like why are you there
just for then other times it does fit
pretty seamless with apps so I don't
really notice it but to say that I don't
notice it all I would completely be
lying because it's there like I don't
know how you can't see it like if you
don't see this then I don't know what
you're looking at because it's there the
knotch
is there but if they were to remove the
knotch I don't think I would be upset at
all I think that I would be okay if it
wasn't there I mean I see why they have
to have the notch here because there's
really nowhere else to put it if they
didn't put the notch there then there
would have to be some sort of a black
bar up here just to house everything
that is inside of this knotch
proximity sensor it has the true depth
camera speakers can't it's got so many
things inside of that little notch today
I mean I get it but how are they gonna
get rid of it for the next phone or are
they not or is this is this the new
normal I thought that I would be taking
a ton of front-facing portrait selfies
but to be honest I really haven't taken
very many I guess in the past week I've
just kind of been playing call of duty
so that's really not something that's
very interesting to take pictures of
especially a front-facing selfie
my friend Joey said he's returning his
iPhone 10 number one because he wasn't a
huge fan of the face ID and number two
because the camera quality was too good
and I a hundred percent get where he's
coming from because when you take a
front-facing picture now I mean it sees
everything
it's like I've taken tons of photos of
my dog I've taken what if I had been
taking pictures of I don't even know
honestly since I got through the iPhone
released week I've basically been
playing video games and it's been great
so yeah I'm looking through here I
haven't really done a whole lot the past
few days here is a cute picture of my
baby boy doggy and his friend Yossi
fires picture my wine fridge while
that's really exciting oh here's a
picture of me and Alex Clark we did a
fun video the whisper challenge video
and we unboxed a very fun the Star Wars
Jedi Challenge game
what else are some wine got a LAN party
more pictures the dog yeah I basically
done a lot so other than taking pictures
my dog I've been very very impressed
with the new snapchat filters now
granted I don't really use snapchat as
much as I used to I feel like most of
the time when I'm going to post
something on snapchat I end up just
posting it on my Instagram stories but I
decided to hop into snapchat and test
out to the face tracking features that
they have now with some of their face
filters and they are very very accurate
I was very shocked hey guys how's it
going I'm just shooting some videos here
but I was testing out a new snapchat
he's tracking on the iPhone 10 so like
it's very very and it's like here's
another one with glasses on like look at
this like I move it and it does I'm so
impressed I'm impressed
oh yeah this is this is great one thing
that snapchat did right is get in early
get the face tracking features and
really implement that to the max on
snapchat let's see what else have I been
doing I mean the phone is obviously so
much faster than the 7 although I did
kind of have that middle phone I had the
iPhone eight between the ten so having
the jump from the 8th to the 10 didn't
really have an overall feeling of that
much difference because both of those
phones the insides are basically the
same thing also the camera quality on
the 8 is almost identical to the 10
being able to have the slo-mo options to
go up to 240 at 1080 is pretty great
although I don't really use it that
often but I have found that I've been
vlogging a lot more on my iPhone because
every time I go to vlog I either don't
have my vlogging camera or the battery
is dead and a lot of you guys didn't
really notice a difference when I went
from this to the other one of course I
can tell because I'm the one filming and
editing and the front-facing camera on
here is obviously not as good as the 4k
Sony that I used to film with but
overall the audio on this thing is great
the video quality looks amazing the
photos look incredible almost too good
and too realistic the battery life I
haven't really noticed that it's been
worse than the 8 or the 7 mostly because
I'm always carrying around a movie so I
am unaware of battery life ever I don't
know if it even gets close to being read
I'm plugging this thing in I've also
really loved having wireless charging
pad one by my bed
by my desk over there and I even have
this one over here which has been my
charger of choice the Mophie wireless
charger so I use this one of my desk and
this one I kind of just move around
throughout the house wherever I happen
to be and in my bedroom I have the
Belkin one I'm not really sure why I
decided to do that I feel like I like
the look of this one and it's a lot
smaller than the Belkin I have some
white lamps in my bedroom so I felt like
the white matched a little bit better
but it really is nice just being able to
roll over from my phone on the charger I
don't have to worry if it's plugged in
or if the dogs gonna jump down and knock
a cord off the bed it's been pretty
great so I know welcome
Justine to wireless charging why did the
pixel to decide not to do wireless
charging I'm so confused I feel like
they rushed the pixel to out just to be
like here's our phone here it is it's
ready but it wasn't it wasn't ready I
will say the front-facing pixel to
portrait mode is really really good I
did a couple tests of that and I'll be
doing a future video here hopefully very
very soon of the note 8 the pixel 2 and
the iPhone 10 doing a little photo
comparison video comparison I know a
bunch of people have already done it but
I'm a little bit late either way even if
I didn't do this video for you guys I
would be doing this for myself anyway so
I just kind of want to test it out and
see for myself what kind of results will
I get stay tuned for that so I guess I
should probably talk about some of the
things that I don't like about the new
iPhone 10 and there's not very many I
know what you're saying just see and
you're buying it this is my video I'm
telling you the things that I like it I
don't like one of the things that I
absolutely do not like it all and it's
been driving me insane is closing apps
now Apple says that you don't have to
close apps because it doesn't really
make a difference it's not gonna kill
your battery it's not gonna do this it's
not gonna do that well I like to close
them I like to be able to just go and
swipe right down here at the bottom see
the things that I have open not
everything that I've opened in the past
two months the problem now is to close
apps you have to swipe up and you just
hold and if there's a there's a delay
now normally you would be able to just
swipe up from here to close but now you
have to hold in and then swipe up or hit
this little button right here so it
definitely takes a few extra seconds
just to close some apps when before used
to be super quick of course this is a
software thing so that is a very very
easy fix hopefully in a future update of
iOS 11 gosh speaking of updates
Wow the biggest troll I feel like in
internet history was the iOS bug where
it turned the letter I to like an A with
a question mark or something there was a
bunch of different things that were
happening you would type a specific
character whether it was an A or an I
and then you would hit Send and in that
sending process between you typing it
and actually hitting Send on Twitter or
Instagram or wherever this would appear
and most of the times when you were
typing it you wouldn't actually see it
until you hit Send are you posted of
whatever it was you're posting and this
infected everyone because it wasn't just
an iPhone 10 thing it was an iOS update
it took them probably like four days
maybe to fix it which I feel like is a
pretty long time especially when the
entire internet was just crumbling at
our fingertips most people on Android
couldn't see the issues so a lot of them
are very confused as to what we were all
complaining about or what we were seeing
the struggle was real thankfully that
update has been updated so if you guys
haven't updated to the latest software
update on your iphones please please -
it will save us all so much hassle so I
guess that's it I really don't have much
more to say that I haven't already said
or I haven't already posted in a
previous video if you guys want to watch
all of those videos I'll put a link in
the description where you can check out
my iPhone 10 playlist there's tons of
fun videos there if you haven't seen
them already and if you have seen them
thank you I appreciate it be sure to
subscribe because I have a bunch of fun
holiday videos coming up which I'm very
excited about also some more fun tech
videos some gaming videos I know a lot
of you guys have been requesting a
Nintendo switch video so yes that is
coming very very shortly as well I feel
so bad I do so many things on this
channel that when somebody gets super
excited about something and they
subscribe off of that specific video and
then I don't do that thing again for a
very long time I just hope that you guys
can find some entertainment in something
here and that's really my my only wish
really well that being said I'm gonna go
and edit this video now so I will see
you guys later bye
[Music]